Україні знадобляться щонайменше кілька десятків років,
щоб розмінувати Донеччину та Луганщину.
Адже за даними ООН, Східна Україна –
один з найбільш замінованих регіонів в світі.
І дійсно,  саме в Україні зафіксовано найбільше інцидентів
із протитранспортними мінами у два попередні роки,
якщо вірити звіту Женевського центру гуманітарного розмінування
та Стокгольмського міжнародного інституту досліджень миру.
Україна у дослідженні яскраво червона на мапі світу серед інших країн.
Експерти посилаються на дані від спостерігачів
та з повідомлення засобів масової інформації.
Навіть такі "гарячі на військові дії" країни, як Афганістан і Сирія,
поступаються Україні за кількістю підривів на протитранспортних мінах минулоріч,
а також за кількістю загиблих внаслідок цих інцидентів.
Утім, якщо говорити про всі типи мін,
то Афганістан залишається найбільш замінованою країною світу.
Загалом же, від всіх типів мін і вибухівок
за роки війни на Донбасі
постраждали і загинули понад півтори тисячі людей.
Щоправда, цьогоріч кількість постраждалих зменшилась більше ніж удвічі,
порівняно з попередніми роками.
Причина - зменшення воєнної активності на Сході України
і роз’яснювальна робота з місцевим населенням,
говорять у британській організації THE HALO Trust,
яка займається розмінуванням в Україні.
Станом на тепер організація виявила і передала українському МНС
більше тисячі мін. А за даними Міноборони,
загалом зусиллями як міжнародних організацій, так і українських військових
вдалося знешкодити понад чверть мільйона вибухонебезпечних предметів.
Проте скільки мін ще і досі лежать на території Донецької та Луганської областей,
ніхто не береться аналізувати.
Адже розміновують лише  підконтрольну Києву територію.
Роботи з виявлення мін не ведуться біля лінії фронту
та на тимчасово окупованій території.
Найбільш замінованими  на Донбасі вважаються території поблизу чотирьох міст –
Маріуполя, Краматорська, Слов’янська та Станиці Луганської.
Що ж до інцидентів з протитранспортними мінами,
їх зафіксували уздовж усієї лінії фронту.